thanks Pete
so the funny thing is is this video
probably goes on for five minutes this
is one audio wanted to get everybody
together to record some general combat
sounds because we needed a general
combat layer whenever anybody would
fight
and we obviously use nothing but the
most professional sound operations right
now obviously following the combat
sounds we need dying sounds and who you
here off the side there was Michael
Koran who was generally the sound
designer through much of the supply
series
success
so again that just goes on and on and on
but that's the kind of thing that you
actually sear on the office when you're
in the middle of development and it's
always amazing when you get an all-call
for some reason it's for something
completely strange sometimes somebody
can walk in your office to say hey we
need German accented voice for X Y & Z
and you have to actually go back and do
it because they've got to find it with
just the right voice as a placeholder
until we actually get a real actor later
so you always have strangeness coming
especially coming out of audio when they
have to use a lot of placeholder early
on so I wanted to start out just kind of
taking a look behind the curtain we've
only got under an hour to kind of go
over some odds and ends we can't tell
you like the complete prehistory as much
as we'd like to it take a long time but
at least touch on the process to come up
with civ 5 what the team went through
and the basically the when they're where
the started was sitting at the prototype
team and this is way way back this is
when the idea was just a concept in like
John Schafer's I just had a he had an
idea and at Firaxis a prototype team
starts out very very basically and it's
small it's always usually a small team
and usually three four people and that's
about it
and the idea of that is to keep
everything else out of the way you're
not worrying about production processes
you're not worrying about tools you're
not worrying about tech you're just
taking the delete' the path of least
resistance couple people coming up with
some ideas making some concept art just
basically a way to visualize these ideas
for a team now normally in a production
environment me being a producer there's
always these timelines goals what's the
list what do we need to really come up
with this has to stay much looser
because with a prototype you can't
necessarily have a strict gang at an end
as a producer I'm always going to
suggest a beginning and an end but
that's not always the way that it works
so you have to kind of keep things loose
because they're else you're not going to
have a really great idea percolate out
of out of out of where that starts so
with time winding goals in an ideal
world a prototype team is going to come
into this and they're gonna have all the
technology they need they're gonna have
all the people that they might need all
the team members they need a concept
from here I need animation from here and
I really want this specific engine to be
working
over here and all this cool rendering
stuff but that's not a reality one of
the realities of game development is
that usually you have this prototype
team you have production teams but
they're usually working on other
projects at the time and you try to line
everything up as a producer so that they
all fit into these neat slots so when
they have it put up a prototype that's
done they suddenly have people that they
can actually start putting into these
slots and actually producing the game so
you try to line everything up that's not
at all usually what happens that again
that's in an ideal world you do the best
that you can that's why the team one has
to stay small at first so if let's say
another project is lagging the prototype
team can continue developing you're not
burning through money and it's a
preference of the designers some
designers like to have a big full team
around them to really start off other
one is just one a couple people it
doesn't get in the way of ideas I love
you've ever had a preference for that in
terms of when you're coming up with
something if you'd rather have something
where you have the resources at your
fingertips or I just want to be in a
room with four guys and forge ahead I
think the interesting thing is we just
had a session here where we were sort of
brainstorming the prehistory game and
you could kind of see that the more
designed by committee we got involved in
that session the kind of crazier the
ideas we're getting pulled in different
directions so I think you do want a
small team just to you want you want to
also focus on kind of what are your
goals for what are you gonna do new this
time what do you want to try where the
CID was talking about it last in the
last session as well about where the
challenge is gonna be some of the things
we know how to do and we're not gonna be
very risky but though there were other
parts of the project where it's like
we're gonna try this brand new thing or
we're gonna try to invent some new style
gameplay that we've never had before and
those are the things you want to focus
most tightly on in this early period I
think four so five it was will hexes
work things like that will one unipro
tile work there were a lot of kind of
core changes that were flipping the
established model on its head and I
think the small team they had you know
and I I joined the team and there were
probably five six people on the team so
they had been working for a while but I
got in there early as well that was sort
of ideal for us by the way funny story I
don't know how many here were in the
very last session with those concepts I
was
sitting over at the side and I had to
lean over to Anton because during the
super early development of brave new
world when we were talking about
concepts what we can do for this next
expansion this is before was really
hammered out and you had great works the
idea of chasing mammoths around the
board prehistory era had come up and I'm
like oh my gosh because we had David
well weren't even around at the time
they had no idea that those
conversations came up so it's funny how
some of those ideas keep regurgitating
themselves when you're talking about
what would be great maybe those cities
we can follow the nameless around soap
and actually I remember
Reeth doing enough research then to try
to figure out like saber-tooth Tigers
are really cool yeah and they were not
mentioned unless session I was really
disappointed I was almost gonna grab
Pete and get that microphone - wait you
forgot about the saber-tooth Tigers but
I've actually done enough research that
gobekli tepe which they have found the
new archaeological site in Turkey it's
about 8,000 years old it's four thousand
years before we start civilization but
yet they have archaeological remains and
stuff like that and I looked at the time
period of the saber-tooth tiger and the
saber-tooth Tigers were still barely
around then so I'm like yes we have some
justification we couldn't have gotten
the saber-tooth Tigers into a
civilization game so they actually did a
really good job of course we had a large
scale because it was an audience but
showing what a typical design meetings
like when you have like five people in
the room and you're just spitballing
ideas for what you think would be a
really neat addition to something that's
an existing franchise so what are the
primary goals for prototype stage
there's a couple things that need to
happen for this team to really have an
idea start the process and come to
fruition and there's two things one is a
vision for the game they've got to have
a vision that they can sell not only to
the director team but for access to
everybody gives us some of the thumbs up
set goes I like it but then again - 2 K
because 2 K is going to basically say
that sounds great we're behind it let's
forge ahead and really start putting all
the cogs into place assembling the team
and the other is just building the
prototype itself so early on this
extremely small team actually gets to
work on the vision itself they're not
necessarily worrying about putting the
game together yet they're just basically
selling the thing that they want to they
want civ 5 to be like so they basically
have to cope with the big bullet points
what's this about X's versus square
what kind of things we're gonna do one
year of your tile they come up with
these big concepts and then visualizes
some way so people that aren't
necessarily playing the game all the
time will really get and understand what
they're trying to do so what we're going
to show you here is super early this was
way back the very first visual set of
imagery that they created to sell this
to the internal director team it's a
really primitive and you're gonna see
some stuff in there that never quite
made it into the game but a lot of the
stuff you'll you'll notice actually came
to be it came to fruition carried
forward into the finished game now one
of the funny things is you this is
normally stuff that's never released
marketing and PR would is not normally
fans of us releasing stuff that's super
not done you know what I mean it's not
something that they don't like to do but
this is really cool but one of the
challenges is has all the placeholder
music and voiceover that we did which is
generally pretty hilarious because it's
it's really bad we actually had to strip
a lot of that out because usually we use
placeholder music it would need to be
licensed there's issues involved so a
lot of us we've replaced it with some
pleasant pre-made civ 5 music so we'll
take a look at this one
something that didn't make it at the
game change of direction
this is when the graphics team looks at
you sideways and goes you wants to do a
Skype on
so a couple things that you'll notice
from that is at the beginning how they
were doing that whole study of hexes
versus squares that now seems like yeah
okay that I don't know why you're
showing me this this is so obvious but
we lived in a total squares environment
at four axis at the time there were no
hexes in any of our game so they were
actually showing this because it was so
out of the ordinary to be talking about
civilization in Texas so they had to
show what the advantage is what the
differences would be when you're
actually playing in squares versus hexes
you saw like the wonder dog originally
they were gonna put on pedestals they
were gonna attach it to the city things
like that show the build up but that was
not something that eventually they
wanted to do there were issues with
having at the time a wandering a hex do
you destroy it we're not sure let's put
up in the hex corner so that way it's
immortal you can't touch it you can't
destroy it it was a design decision that
John eventually made that to carry it
forward that way and a lot of other
stuff you sell is just stuff that
continued forward into the game from the
views that basically the way that the
world looked and felt that was all
carried forward into the finished
product so the next is the prototype
itself what do you do when you don't
have the tech to do this we weren't
working in unreal we basically have to
create tech that we want to we want to
use so for we use gamebryo so we had an
engine to work with we knew that that
was something we were going to move away
from because we wanted to do something
very specific for this so what what does
the design team do to create a prototype
to basically show 2k that this game is
going to be working and for someone like
John Schaefer who at the time was an
avid modern modern of civilization for
he makes it in Civilization for and this
is an example of in early screenshot of
the game it actually went way back into
his archives and pulled these out and we
included the comment that happened to
come across that was along with this
screenshot that's funny every sieve damn
that I've been involved in had this
exact bug every single time that we've
played and Denis thanked me for being
really bad about deleting all the emails
so there was still my email years later
yeah and you can see they it's the same
engine and he eventually pinged the
graphics team and said can we take the
squares and just shift every other row
over one half of a square so that was a
big that was a big first step to just
getting
these pseudo hexes actually showing up
in the game this other email was kind of
interesting and telling too and you can
actually see some of the old squares off
to the right in the desert that shows
where that came from but this is from
the writer at the time who was doing a
lot of design assistants early on in the
prototype saying this is really strange
and it's really cool like they have some
superior tactic to their attack
piecemeal and responded by building an
actual front line of Units which is
moving to sweep their cities what a
blast
this was new to CID before with the
stack of doom well you know this is this
is just Civ history he'd move it and you
attack there wasn't a whole lot of
tactics involved so this is the first
time we actually got to play with this
within the civilization 4 engine so one
of the one of the many of the challenges
that we had was creating an entirely new
render we didn't have the advantage
anymore of just falling back on gamebryo
or pulling unreal off the shelf we had
to create a Malaysian from scratch
because there's a lot of things that we
wanted to do that we couldn't really get
out of gamebryo with the with the
civilization 4 engine it was a very we
had some very specific needs that we
wanted in our new game and so the
graphics team went to work on building
one that this group was gonna take time
and thus the prototyping within
civilization for that game existed in
the civilization for for quite some time
in the development there is a
significant ramp up time obviously
there's a lot of work to be done before
this is actually playable it's not just
the graphics layer it's not just
generating the Train it's not just
creating a whole new language and an
engine for the UI it was all of these
things had to be done from scratch and
with that comes a very slow process of
iteration I'm an instant gratification
kind of guy anybody on my team America
I'm looking at you knows that I'm like
this doesn't look great how long is it
gonna take three months and I'm like oh
why not win it tomorrow when I next week
and it's it's just an impatience to me
because I know whenever the graphics
team makes these big steps
it just makes such a huge difference in
the game you see these amazing things
start to happen but it just takes a lot
of time so there's an example of this we
can see on the screenshot on the Left
where the engine was in its earliest
state when it was first just generating
a height map and basically showing hey
hills and mountains we've got something
rendering on screen and the word ended
up we've got a screenshot of brave new
world there which is basically the same
engine that we shipped with in 2010
albeit some minor graphics upgrades so
you can see where that was in December
5th 2008
and then that slow march of iteration
March 3rd and 2009 and you can see we
started to pull in some civilization for
resources we started to get some forests
on the map you can see some rivers
drawing around December 5th 2008 more
general iteration again it's just a slow
crawl we've got some mountains in the
game
June 1st 2009 which is our first UI
coming on board this is one was close to
being playable you could play it
somewhat at this point not completely
but the UI system all those systems are
starting to come online you'll notice
the end turn button had found its way up
into the upper right hand corner for
some reason eventually you know
obviously you know where it ended up but
it's interesting as we explored all of
these systems and just started playing
with these systems the directions that
they wind the mini-map it's in a
different spot there definitely some
changes there July 4th 2009 first
passive really early early water that we
had in the game and again you see the UI
continues to change bottom left unit
panel changed again these things chain
are gonna change 100 times between when
you start when you finish because you
can do the best comp in the world for UI
but once you get it in the game and
you're playing with it you start to see
where things are where things are going
wrong or things need to be improved
September 1st 2009 this is exactly one
year from release of the game the next
water pass waters starting to really
come together we can see the Mauser
really come together there's a little
bit of a lack of definition in detail
but that will be coming November 1st
2009 fog of war this is when we had the
very first past fog of war and so you
see the light fog and the dark fog it's
just existing as big black circles at
this time and you can see we also have a
placeholder unit there and wheat which
is not done January 21st 2010 really
starting to come together this is really
getting closer and closer to what we
we're really expecting to see you can
see that farms still have a little while
to go but the general field and look of
the game is getting closer to where we
were eventually starting to end up and
then finally when we ship the game this
is where we ended up so you can see a
lot of the final graphics work the
things that really make it shine are
going to happen in those last few months
because you can get to a certain point
but it's the last 20% when you get 0 to
80%
you're gonna see some differences but
the last 20% really makes these
different eight months before we shift
right yeah eight months before you
shipped but not just eight months there
comes a point when you you have to stop
that graphics work you're gonna get into
alpha and you should be pretty locked
down by that point they're gonna be
refining at that point but the general
look we probably had about three more
months of iteration to really get the
look where we wanted to prefer between
there and there so it's it's an exciting
process when you actually see this stuff
really start to solidify at the end so
with that we also had to take care of
making an intro movie every civilization
game has an intro movie every
civilization game had some sort of
montage and it's happens over and over
and over again because we have a game
that is completely wide open right so
how do you make a story-driven intro
movie for a game that's basically played
differently by the player every time and
that's always been a challenge so we've
always had these same montages of
history whether it's like whenever we
had the caveman painting images and
would cut back and forth to all these
some periods in time if you look at
warlords it was just a basically a war
montage to kind of highlight the
different things we were focusing on
there at the beginning of sift 5 you had
the flyovers of a city going to war and
a king walking up and getting crowned
and again there's a lot of these methods
that we use too many times that um
because we couldn't really think of a
better way to approach this so with
civilization 5 we wanted to attack this
in a different way we wanted to put a
face on this that really gave it a human
face I just blew through all three of
these by the way so finding a human
element and the best way we could do
that we thought is to have a character
one character and you know like in Civ 4
they didn't quite have a character at
the beginning but then they had Leonard
Nimoy kind of coming in he was basically
the end game character whatever tech
quotes came up he kind of did work on
the dawn of man but what if we could
take that character right from the
beginning and so we were going through
many different pieces of script work
trying to find that character we had
multiple people writing scripts and they
weren't quite working at the end of some
you'd have funeral pyres where the
firewood or the father would die and the
Sun would burn him and it evoked images
of Star Wars at the end where he's
burning Darth Vader
weren't quite working so we finally land
them on a place that we thought worked
really well the script work we thought
we could get this this great actor if we
got like Morgan Shepherd he had a he had
a fantastic voice and we focused more on
the voice instead of having a celebrity
character this time around even though
Morgan Shepherd I thought is it as a
Star Trek nerd I there's a mortgage
Shepherd was a hit for me because he was
an all kinds of Star Trek stuff but his
voice was perfect he had that great
raspy voice that we could take all
through the game and we could introduce
him as a character the beginning but
what I want to show you next is a super
super early cut of the intro movie again
this is this is just where the sausages
made something you wouldn't normally see
but it's really interesting to me to see
when you go to a digital house what they
give you to block out the scene and
basically say you gave us your script
this is what we think these scenes
should look like and we're like that's
that's awesome so here this is now this
is what again final music we couldn't
have liked the placeholder music that's
in there but
some of this get a little creepy by the
way when you actually see them
placeholder pieces
I like it it likes it bye welcome back
my son Arthur yak missed you have the
men begun setting up the encampment yes
Father
god this is a lush fertile land I think
we can make a home here I agree
you will do well in this place come sit
with me
and listen I have had a dream of our
people's future it was glorious
I saw people spreading throughout the
land all across the oceans expanding
action and discovering new people and
great riches in faraway lands
that button to small Newman's honoring
the gods which reached up to brush the
very fabric of the heavens with great
buildings of stone he never served on
the last the streets were filled with
our people in numbers beyond curtain
there was suffering as well the great
internment brought about by the tourism
legs are strong and we brought victory
to my people there my dream ended and my
story as well for it has been revealed
to me that it is your future he's
totally plotting to kill him that's what
it looks awkward family hug faces or
hurt people
I envy you my boy your decisions will
shave the history itself grown hours
with my blessing and decide your future
I think I'm glad we took the hug out yes
that's our Lord play the signs as though
so that's what's so much fun about this
digit put together this whole thing for
us and we know where it came out we
obviously saw the final results of that
video and they probably did the best
intro movie that we've had in the series
I just love the work that they did but
it's so much fun actually blocking out
the movie when you're actually looking
at it you can see right away the things
that aren't gonna work like you're like
that hug is really awkward when you see
it and even if it when it's finally
animated smoothly and correctly you know
it just doesn't feel right so it's stuff
like that we took out the helicopter
camera at the end where they did the the
multiple zoom ends on the Sun that
didn't quite work so it's a really
interesting part of production to be
able to go through this process with a
house like diging now the next thing
that we had to solve is leader
presentation each game of Civ has a
different way that they present their
leaders we've done it where they just
reacted they didn't say anything the
text said it and then they just make
gestures in the background like be in a
civilization 3 or solution 2 they had
pre-canned animations Civ Rev we had
four acts lish which exactly half the
people in here hate and the other half
think is amusing and funny that was the
same thing that was used in pirates so
what do we do to bring to elevate this
we have to do very realistic scenes John
thought it was very important to have
these guys in their environment gives
them extra context really gives them
extra flavor so what if we do real-world
languages this would be cool and be a
first for us so one of the problems that
we have with that is finding actors that
can do difficult or dead languages and
also the experts needed to actually
translate our scripts into something
that we can use we had an excellent
external resource that partnered with us
to actually go basically all over the
globe and find all these difficult
languages find the experts these experts
would translate the scripts if it was a
completely dead language and they
couldn't find anybody to speak it they
translate it and put in and put it into
phonetics basically so they if they find
somebody that could actually read it
they'd sound like the right person so
one example of this one of the more
difficult ones was Genghis Khan finding
an actor that could actually speak the
language is not an easy language to
speak was difficult and we ended up
having to make some compromises to find
the person who could do it so the one
that you're used to seeing in game
it's a dangerous guy you start a game
next to Genghis Khan or Montezuma or any
of those you generally know that it's
going to be a difficult game because
he's eventually going to come running
across your borders so we had to kind of
convey that kind of attitude interactor
but the only actor we could find was a
little bit on the young side instead
my sick engine to keep my mother happy
but the Woodsen
so with an example like that we actually
had when we actually had it hooked up we
had some samples hooked up to Genghis he
didn't sound right because he was this
big sinister imposing guys got less
armor on and everything but the voice
was coming through just a little too
high it just he didn't sound quite right
so they actually had to do some
post-production work on the voice just
to lower it down get the feel that we
wanted so all of these were we're
challenging Montezuma was very
challenging to find somebody who could
actually speak the language and act so
that was one of the really fun parts of
the project is just going through this
process finding all the right people
it's not always simple though as this
was the first time we've done that we've
got very Western views of what's right
and what's not right our public
perception versus what's in game some of
the issues that we had with this where
some of the leaders didn't sound quite
right to the locale that's actually
listening to these leaders and so
Empress Wu we had a fine script we had a
great actress looked good for the body
type everything sounded good
technically all correct but because she
was an empress the local dialect
apparently was not quite right the
accident wasn't right she was speaking
more of a for the time apparently a
peasant Chinese instead of our peasant
Mandarin versus a the way a royal would
speak these are things that we did not
know about there weren't necessarily
even things that regular localization
team would know about but people that
really studied empress wu from that area
thought that that was not right the
other one the other example we have is
Sejong of Korea chose to analyze the
Oh God this one we thought was perfect
it was spoke perfect it matched the body
type he had a really great performance
but unfortunately st. wrong is a
legendary legendary character over in
Korea and his voice was not nearly at
least two again the locale as commanding
and just it should have been deeper it
should have been more bold everything
that people expect to hear in their mind
when they see one of those legendary
characters speaking it wasn't quite
right and even Sejong went as far as say
a crowdsourced effort to do an entirely
new voiceover that went pretty far I
mean we even had to kick come to us and
say what do you think if we actually put
this together for them to actually patch
it in but as we know lip-syncing our
leaders was a very difficult and
time-consuming process but it's
something that we really took forward as
we went forward working when expansions
etcetera we really needed to pay more
attention to these kind of details that
we hadn't had to worry about before and
with that I'll hand it over to Ed to do
a little study on what's in a name and
Dennis just segwayed towards the
expansions I took over as lead designer
once we started the dlc and expansions
on co5 so first thing I started thinking
about was what kind of new systems do we
want to have in the game what's gonna be
fun and exciting about the gameplay in
the expansions versus what we had in the
base game and then all of a sudden
Dennis also came to me and said what's
the name of the expansion and I was
thinking game play I had no idea about
name right away so I gave him a quick
response I knew that the first expansion
was going to have religion in it
religion was gonna be really important
in the Middle Ages and Renaissance I
also knew that we had planned some
scenarios to go with each of the
expansions and then I was gonna do a big
scenario on the Renaissance period so my
first answer was a Renaissance hoping
that that would stick for at least a
little while he wouldn't come back the
next day asking for a different name and
we actually went with Renaissance
probably for four or five months that
that was the plans marketing came and
met with us and we were planning to roll
that out as the definitive name for the
first expansion we thought it had a
positive meaning for the series there
were some things we were doing like we
were taking the combat formula
and 100 the 10-point hit point scale
that was in the base game and throwing
that out and replacing it with a hundred
a point hit point scale and so there was
sort of a rebirth in some of the
original systems that was going into
that expansion so it seemed to fit but
then we kept having problems there were
people that couldn't spell Renaissance
does it have one end doesn't have two
answers ev1s how many vowels does it
have where you know internally everybody
learned to spell Renaissance after those
five months were up internally but we
kept realizing other people aren't going
to be able to hang with that so we took
another look at it we thought about
could we simplify it what's the core
essence of what we're doing and that's
obviously how we ended up with gods and
Kings for the name for the first
experience now a funny thing for this
this was right around the time when when
Ed had this idea gods and Kings because
it really fit in well with the whole
religion aspect of the game that we were
introducing Exodus gods and Kings was
announced and this worried us was going
to come out at the same time but we had
already submitted this name for approval
and went up the chain and they said well
you know the name matches up with this
movie that's coming out but Exodus gods
and Kings got delayed so we were first
and so kept that we shall yeah so it
stuck then we got to a second expansion
and with a second expansion we also had
to come up with a name and again Dennis
came with me and then we knew we were
gonna have a World Congress we knew that
we were gonna focus on the modern
through the end of the game so it was
gonna be post Renaissance but it's
really gonna be focusing on kind of the
globalization of the world and in the
20th century and so one world what's the
first name that we came up with it
seemed to make sense it didn't seem like
there was anything out there that had
used that exact name before
didn't seem yes that was the problem so
we actually I think we were six months
from releasing brave new world and we
still had one world as the name and then
I saw some ads on TV for the upcoming
Survivor season and they were also gonna
call their season survivor one world and
we started thinking about it
did rolled off yeah Dennis voted that
one off the island so we started going
back to the drawing board and the next
thing that came to mind and you can tell
right away there might be some problems
with that it was cool I've had this sort
of weird Illuminati kind of connotation
with it
we also found there was a World
Wrestling Federation kind of connotation
to it so we decided that's probably too
dark and too weird the wrestling the
when we found out there wasn't a
wrestling event named after New World
Order that probably sealed the deal
right there that we had to accent so
it's at this point that I was starting
to really think about the ideology
system and figure out how the conflict
between communism fascism and the
Democratic people was gonna play out I
started thinking about kind of
literature we were putting great works
in so I started thinking about that
literature of the early 20th century
period and Huxley's brave new world came
to mind I threw that out as an idea and
and that has stuck and that's where we
ended up with that so another thing I
wanted to talk about because there's
been a very interesting pathway where
just some of the work that we've been
done has led in the direction we didn't
expect at all is the AI system for so v
I came on to su v I had two roles one
was to make sure that the gameplay
software that we were building was going
to support what John wanted to do and
then I was also going to take the
overall leadership for our AI systems
now that AI systems let's if I were
complex enough that we had four
different engineers working on various
parts of the AI and the way we made that
happen is we broke it up into different
components and you can see that on the
right-hand side but part of that process
of figuring out how the AI was going to
be put together with sort of figuring
out what the difficult spots were going
to be what our challenges were and I
identified three or four different
things here one is just that
civilization such a long game if it
takes 20 hours to to get all the way
towards the end of the game it's going
to be tough to test and balance those
systems that
just require that much time to be put in
to get to it
the other thing is it's not the same
game every time you play that's what
makes it so wonderful the procedurally
generated map gives you extreme
replayability gives you that sense of
wonder when you're exploring the map
early in the game but it means that the
AI is going to react differently to a
new situation every time you put it out
there on the map and that's going to
make it tough to create an AI that you
know exactly how it's going to behave in
every situation we also plan for Civ
five that we're gonna have a lot of
unique different play styles for the
differences a lot of different bonuses
we started with 20 in the base game we
ended up with 43 once we're finished
with brave new world so just the
different combinations of what if you
have a sieve that loves to expand and
grab every single space to settle a city
like the Iroquois or the Aztecs and how
does that interact with you know if you
have a map that's full those sibs or you
have a map that has them right next to
Venice who's not going to expand beyond
the one city there's lots and lots of
combinations to think about and then
even though we had a good plan for
segmenting the work and dividing the AI
up into the different component
subsystems that we're going to allow us
to work on that independently how do we
ensure that those AI subsystems are
going to talk together right communicate
they're going to be aware of what's
going on they're going to have share a
common viewpoint also the game world so
the interaction between those subsystems
was also a huge challenge so I'm not
going to try to talk about you know GDC
game developers in depth how did we
solve this software talk here but what I
do want to do is talk about one key tool
that we used that actually helped us
with with pretty much all these
different problems and it's sort of
become a staple of how we develop a AI
at Firaxis and so that's our secret
sauce it's not not the wonderful UI here
that's not the secret sauce here but
this is our primitive UI that we use to
drive what we call our autoplay system
and our autoplay system allows you to
fire up a game and have the AI play
head-to-head with each other
you can have
as many different you know set up the
map the way you would normally set up a
game and then you can have this system
run and the game will play itself for as
many turns as you want you can have it
stopped after ten turns or 50 turns or
hundred turns and after the autoplay
session takes that break you can have it
returned as any of the different players
in the game so you can see what the game
world looks like from that players point
of view so kind of from that simple
start we were able to to get a lot of
analysis of how they I was balanced how
well it was performing and one way we do
that is by just generating a huge amount
of logged data kind of recording every
single decisions they I make so we can
go back and analyze it so these are log
files they'll have things broken down by
different categories of the game of
diplomacy log a city construction log an
overall economic performance log and you
can actually if you guys go out there on
online you can search for how to turn
these things on you can turn them on and
look at them yourself but as you'll see
from the next slide they can be a little
bit unscrew table okay a little slide a
little sidebar here so remember that
scene the matrix and like Neos in having
this kung fu fight does this a trennis
roundhouse kick then it cuts back to on
the ship and they're all like staring at
the screen with numbers going down go oh
look what he just did and that's that's
everybody in the audience is like I
don't understand what they're looking at
that's how I feel when I walk into the
design office and they're all poring
over this with the screen full of data
and they're going oh my God look what
you just did you just roundhouse kicks
easily that's that's exactly how this is
so yeah it's great stuff though you can
tell you know how many times they build
spearmen versus horsemen how many times
did they capture city not capture city
when they tried to attack it this is
actually this little snippet a log here
is a summary log that we created we had
such in-depth logging that took too much
time to go through them in detail and we
had to kind of get a quick overview of
how militaristic the game world had been
how many battles and wars were fought
and so we ended up rolling up data into
a higher-level macro log that condensed
the information and gave us a quick
summary of when people went to war when
the people went to peace and so forth
and just as an example of how we use
that type of AI analysis is I used a
bunch of AI autoplay runs to help out
the beyond earth team when they were
putting that game together and you can
see examples of that on this screen here
just a simple little excel chart I put
together
as a capsule summary of all those
different runs but what I was trying to
look for was how active were the AIS and
going to war how often were they doing
friendly things like offering packs of
cooperation there's a little section
there highlighted in red and that was
showing that in the course of a beyond
earth game condom nations which is the
same thing as a denunciation and so if I
pretty much those were happening between
50 and 100 times per game I was kind of
way out of control in that particular
build so I did another tuning pass
changed the condemnation levels to bring
them down into a more reasonable zone
and then we did so a few three more runs
after that and the numbers looked a lot
better so it's just sort of an example
of how an autoplay system helped us
develop soup 5 so why am I talking this
much about the autoplay system in the
middle of kind of a funny recap of so
five stories well we actually didn't
leave off the autoplay system here it's
sort of come back and emerged as sort of
a new thing within the Civic community
and that's kind of our summary here
they're a useful tool but can they
actually be a way to have more fun with
soup 5 as well and that's this was very
surprising to us but the Civic community
I don't know if anyone here is involved
with this but if so feel free to stand
up and take credit for it but what's
happened is is specifically the Civ
reddit community which has just
developed over the last three four years
really and blossomed and now is a
vibrant part of our fan base decided
that they were going to put together a
couple earth maps and try to battle sibs
out starting from their respective real
world historical start locations and see
who the winner would be and it took a
couple tries to get this right the first
couple games
it's got snagged by technical problems
and so forth they were trying to have as
many as 60 civilizations on the map at
the same time we had four axis only
support 22 so you know they were way
past the normal limits
but they've stuck with it and now this
is their third iteration of it it's
civilization five battle royale mark 2
and we'll head we got a couple screens
here showing what they've done with it
this is what a game world might look
like this is the Americans in blue
fighting the Canadians who are in red
you notice that Canadians are doing well
here they've got a big chunk of the
Midwest there's a Mexican army coming up
along the Gulf of Mexico and then I
believe it's the the Sioux who are up in
the Pacific Northwest all the different
conflicts between the nations get named
so you can see here that it is the Bison
war that is going on between the Sioux
and the Mexicans right now it always
amazes me how closely this follows
real-life you can see Boston on the
Great Lakes and New York celebrate where
Orlando is right now so lots of fun but
they're just fascinating to watch and
not only do they have screen shots like
this but they will publish twice a week
episode episodic content of what's
happened they get guests members of the
civilization community that come on and
do the the little funny recaps and and
kind of play-by-play of what's going on
so this particular Second Battle Royale
is up to part 16 and you can go and you
can review any of those they're all
available in the they have a dedicated
civil RAL reddit forum and then they
have animated world maps showing the
extent of all the different empires this
will animate as you play through and
kind of review the entire state of the
game which is now up to gate turn 179
and yes they even have newspapers so
this is the European this is the latest
edition just came out all the latest
conflicts in Europe we have you know
embedded pictures from the game world as
well and lines as well as articles there
and the community has even gone so far
as there's a World Congress where
they're discussing what's going on with
each of the different civilizations
there's some type of stock exchange I
haven't figured it out yet but there's
some way where each of the countries are
valued in relation to each other and you
can actually go and support the
different civilizations in the game and
make charitable donations towards them
and what happens is if they are knocked
out they find a good cause some type of
charitable organization within the
country that has just been eliminated
from the game and take all that money
and donate it there so Civ autoplays
doing good for the world who would have
thought but that's what's happening okay
we've got one more interesting autoplay
story that kind of led us to also in a
different direction and the sort of as
I've explained here coming in everyday
part of my regular routine was get the
latest software get the the build made
and go ahead and run a couple other
place make sure nothing is crashing
where else other people will be running
on a place and they'll bring me crash
reports and I did have just the case
like that on su5 where I came in the
morning in a crash during the autoplay
was reported to me so I started looking
at it and the interesting thing was that
there was a crash building a palace okay
and if you've played sieve five you know
you can't build a palace in survive it's
already there you know when you start
out boom you've got a capital city the
palace is there so how actually can you
build a palace and see if five so I
thought this was most peculiar and I
started looking into it what's going
wrong where's the bug in our system
where all of a sudden someone's building
a palace and that's crashing
well the problem was that it wasn't a
human player it wasn't even a regular AI
SIV that was building a palace it was
the barbarian player and the code that
we put in force if five so that
barbarians are allowed to ransack your
city and take a lot of gold from it but
never actually capture the city that
code was not working right and the bug
was that they were letting the
barbarians take ownership of that city
and the barbarians being very smart
players say everybody else has got a
palace I want one too
and so they started building it so I was
thinking actually this is pretty
brilliant this is actually a really
smart barbarian and I hated to fix the
bug but you know I had to do it but it
sort of left a sort of kernel of an idea
with me
that you know maybe this was cool maybe
this was fun maybe we should let
barbarians have a bigger role in the
civil I've universe and you know so the
barbarians took over city they thought a
palace might be cool they built one so I
started reading for the gods in King's
expansion pack a bunch of history of the
citizen we might put in I got to a book
and this was the cover of the book it's
a picture of Attila he has recently
moved into somebody else's palace and
taken over it this is a picture from art
museum in Budapest and to me it just
reminded me of this whole auto-play
scenario this was the barbarians they
have just taken over city and they're
quickly putting up a palace for a Atilla
and so I thought that's kind of fun
let's let's go ahead and until has never
been in the game before he's one of the
kind of most feared they called him the
scourge of God one of the most feared
leaders in the classical world maybe we
should go ahead and this time you know
put him in as a sieve leader and so you
can kind of look at this artwork and
then sort of see where we ended up with
for Attila and it's there's sort of the
same idea there he's recently moved into
is his throne room he looks like he's
just came in from horse riding but he's
occupying the throne and happy there and
okay well maybe not
even what he's saying be wary of
crossing me lest your wealth end up at
my feet so you know he's got the right
attitude for the Barbarian recently
moved into the palace I thought so we're
gonna put this Huns in the game we start
editing the XML to get them in the game
I start looking at all the different
things you have to put in to add a new
civilization in and there was a problem
I got to trying to populate the city
name list for the Huns and I said well
let me grab my book on the Huns to
figure out what cities they founded and
they didn't found any cities none so we
looked at it and they took over this
Roman city they took over this other
Roman city they took over a third Roman
city they took over a Byzantine city
they you know they they just conquered
cities they didn't actually take any of
themselves so what are we gonna do so we
have a couple different ideas maybe we
use the different tribes of Huns when
they're out on the steppes and they were
broken up into different tribes we could
kind of come together to come up with
enough names to make up a city less
didn't sound super interesting we could
name him after the different leaders
after Attila came through and he took
over a lot of territory and the Empire
fell apart a little bit after that but
it it stuck around long enough somewhere
over in Bulgaria or Hungary - we could
probably come up with a list of 10 or 12
chieftains and use their names of cities
but none of those seemed really very
exciting and so we decided maybe the
best idea in history they took the
cities from other people maybe they
should take the city names from other
people as well so this is a soup 5
screenshot and you can see that the the
great Hunnish city of Spokane is at the
north part of the map they've stolen
that one from the Americans and the
great hunter city of Winchester is to
the southwest of that that was stolen
from the England English and then
there's it's a palapa which they stole
from the Aztecs and a bunch of other
examples I think there's a Korean
example and
Persian City as well in there so this
actually became kind of fun from a
gameplay point of view because normally
you're trying to figure out early in the
game of Civ who the other players in the
map are who you got to face you know are
those powers they're gonna sweep over
the other continent and here you
actually as you build your settlers and
found your cities you get little kernels
snippets of intelligence about the other
players of the game so as soon as we
tried this out we decided it was fun it
was actually all the way the codebase
worked right out of the box it was
already set up that if it ran out of
city names on a list it would just grab
one from another player so I didn't even
have to write any special code to have
it worked like this so it was win-win
situation and we went with it back to
Dennis alright I just I just want to
touch on a couple things as we go
through there's some just funny clips
that we dug up to kind of wrap things up
in a couple places where things didn't
quite go as planned beware this is
another early storyboard in progress for
the gods everything's intro the audio
will be mismatched there's something
specific I wanted to show you in the
middle of this
as plashing ambition spurred the
appetite of armies our signal gave way
to sword and shield
consumed by war little salts rushing to
action on impulse without religious
devotion
but even then many were consumed by
zelicah filling them with suspicion okay
let's talk about this scene just for a
second
so you sometimes get in tunnel vision
when you're working on a game in terms
of what's historically accurate would be
cool and when we were early in the
process and this isn't super early you
can see this is the third the third
iteration of the block out that we were
working on with the house this was
plastic wax it did our intro movie for
this
when 2k came knocking on our email door
buying guys we can't show burning humans
alive and we were like it actually
happened why not we can we can add more
flames we can consume you know we don't
have to show it and there's like no no
it's a 10 so your 10 year olds gonna be
watching this and it might be a little
disturbing so like okay so we went
through back and forth probably four
times down to where we only showed maybe
a wisp of cloth and just the feet and we
were like can we show the feet and then
they said no because they're gonna see
the feet wiggling and the flames are
gonna be coming up it just is is a
horrible idea and eventually we had to
land on you did actually see the feet
briefly but then they were off-camera
and the flames roared up
but it's one of those things where
sometimes these situations happen when
if you're anybody not working on it
they're like that's absurd how could you
possibly think that's okay and at the
time you're like it's completely normal
we're burning a witch it's fine
easy box the disco to get you to be
where they are
that's nightmare stuff and sometimes we
come in with the first thing that we
normally do when we come in the morning
is check the Auto Bild
not really download the Auto Bild see
what might have broke from the day
before just generally see if
everything's okay this is one of those
morning's where everything broke except
perhaps work that right now pay
attention to the archers on the
elephant's lover to the right that's
unfortunate
oh my god tick
Timmy's dead they're killing us
this one's my favorite well it gets
better
oh my god it's saying these things all
these videos were basically used that
get fired off to some team member or
saying something I'm not working here
and then you look at them like now five
years later and it's like wow that's
pretty funny
don't delete your email so with that we
only have time for just a handful of
questions so have Pete run around if
anybody does have any questions anybody
we've got a question in the back here
real quick yeah so question on how the
AI process works when you're developing
it is it a lot of getting basically
really good players and trying to
understand what basic good strategies
are or is there a lot of just trying
lots of random different things and
seeing what floats to the top I think
it's more of the former and one tool
that we have that's a very useful tool
is we have a secret but not so secret
external group of testers a lot of them
are really really strong players of the
series we have some you know a wide
range of ability levels there as well to
want to test the game from as many
different angles as possible but those
people are very very good at identifying
you know kind of core strategies that
are gonna win we're at a I may be weak
and and one of the things that we did
with that external group is we would
actually ask them for what we considered
AI bloopers so anytime the AI was just
obviously making a poor decision or was
obviously taking a strategic path that
wasn't you know gonna end up being a
dead end
we'd have those people kind of either
send us games where they could
demonstrate that or just describe it to
us and those were always great areas for
us to shore up they
so I think the former approach is
definitely a path that we take and in
terms of just trying a bunch of
different things we sort of got the
trying a bunch of different things
naturally from the AI autoplay system we
have a lot of different we had without
going into too a lot of technical detail
we had a flavor system that dried the AI
in different directions and so based on
the fact that the flavor settings were
wildly different for some of our
civilizations when we ran a lot of auto
place we would get a lot of different
outcomes and we could see things like
for instance I think it's still true in
Civ v that Alexander plays one of the
very strongest games of any of your AI
opponents because he's really really
good at getting some city-states
allied to his side and building this
huge coalition of city-states that stuff
to dislodge and we definitely saw that
kind of behavior in the auto play games
okay would playing at the deity level
against the AI any suggestions I've got
2000 hours on episode 5 already and and
daily is almost impossible I've beaten
down a mortal a few times I've beaten on
deity once okay well if you're bound to
determine to beat deity I think probably
the the best tip there is there are a
lot of let's play videos
Madge in who's one of our external
testers who's here at fracks Archon with
us today has posted a bunch of those but
he's not the only one that authors those
and they have like specific tips or you
can watch them play versus deity and you
know I think that's probably the best
best way to make sure you beat that I
actually myself have never beaten deity
I haven't gone on a huge series of runs
to try to beat and beat it I like to be
able to play sort of without trying to
exploit the AI all the time so I've only
been normal immortal myself
it's XCOM that I have this morbid
fascination with making sure I win on
Ironman but with SIP 5 I kind of step
back and try to play it a little bit
more like the designer wants to play it
ed in Denis everybody
thanks everybody